&gt;&gt; Here, the correct answer was b. Great job if you got that one right. First,
let's solve this inequality for y. I can subtract 10 from both sides to get 5 y
on the right, and 2 x minus 10 on the left. Then, I divide each term by 5. So, 2
5th x minus 2 is greater than or equal to y. We're used to seeing y on the left
side of the inequality, so let's rearrange this inequality. So, I have y is less
than or equal to 2 5th x minus 2. Notice this inequality symbol is pointing
towards the y in both inequalities. That's a great way that you can check to
make sure you wrote it correctly. First, we plot our y-intercept at negative 2.
And then, we use our slope, 2 5th. We rise 2 units and run to the right 5 units.
So there's the next point. I use a solid line here because that could be equal
to the line. We have y is less than or equal to, so points on this should
satisfy this inequality. Again, I'm going to use the origin as a test point, and
I get 0 is less than or equal to negative 2. This statement's not true, so I
don't want this region. I need to shade below. And here's our graph.